Wonder Woman might be one of the most powerful
beings in the DC universe, but one of her
costumes in Zack Snyder’s Justice League,
now streaming on HBO Max, really pushes the
boundaries of believability.
After receiving a message from her mother,
Queen Hippolyta , in the aftermath of an attack
in Themyscira , Diana Prince travels from
Paris to the ancient Shrine of the Amazons.
Clad in a crisp white trench coat and heels,
Diana explores the ruins, discovering a distinct
arrow.
Quickly, Diana crafts a makeshift torch and
drops down into a mysterious and shrouded
tomb to explore it and read the runes beneath
the surface ... but for some reason, Diana
makes that drop in impeccable white stiletto
heels, landing perfectly without hurting herself
or even damaging her footwear.
There's no question that Diana, an Amazonian
goddess with super strength and a whole host
of incredible powers, can do anything she
sets her mind to ... but for anyone who's
ever worn heels in real life, the sequence
is pretty silly.
Fans took to Twitter to share their reactions,
which ranged from mild outrage to complete
astonishment.
One user wrote,
"They couldn't get wonderwoman some more comfortable
shoes for the descent into the center of the
Earth?"
Another user agreed, Tweeting,
"Tell me how WonderWoman jumps down a deep
pit lands on her feet and doesn't break her
heels?
Must be wonder shoes."
Another Twitter user wrote.
“Currently watching the SnyderCut it's certainly
better.
But there's a scene [where] Wonder Woman jumps
down a deep hole while wearing heels.
When she lands they making a gentle 'tap'.
They'd be decimated surely?"
Meanwhile, one user had a simple question:
"Why does Wonder Woman have to wear heels?"
In response to comedian Leslie Jones, who
live-tweeted the entire movie and noticed
that apparently one of Diana's superpowers
is "clean clothes" — referencing her spotless
white coat — one Twitter user weighed in,
she joked,
"She's Wonder Woman so of course she has a
constant supply of dirt resistant clothing
that is made by a high-end designer it is
also the reason that the heels don't break
off of her shoes and make her fall down."
However, some fans thought the moment made
Diana even cooler.
One user wrote,
"Diana's heels must be one of the most sought
after items by ladies."
While another user wrote,
"The most impressive thing in this movie so
far is wonder woman jumping down hundreds
of feet into the underground cave and landing
with those heels intact."
For some fans, the heels were something they
just couldn't accept; as one Twitter user
put it,
"When aquaman swims in jeans and boots i can
accept it.
but i draw the line at wonder woman wearing
strictly heels."
However, as any action movie fan can tell
you, women performing completely unrealistic
stunts in spiky, uncomfortable stiletto heels
is nothing new.
In recent movies, starlets like Bryce Dallas
Howard, Sienna Miller and Rachel McAdams have
been forced into a form of footwear that any
woman knows is notorious for their limited
mobility and overt discomfort — and not
only that, they're then tasked with performing
outrageous action sequences in shoes that
would never withstand a difficult situation.
Perhaps the most controversial pair of stiletto
heels in recent memory were Howard's in 2015's
Jurassic World, where she’s just tottering
around the dangerous park and fleeing dinosaurs
in a pair of patent leather stilettos that
would definitely impede her movement pretty
intensely.
Eventually, the backlash over Claire's footwear
became so intense that the film's director,
Colin Trevorrow , was forced to comment, claiming
that Howard herself insisted on the shoes.
Apparently, this was true, and the heels,
which Howard trained in especially for the
role, made a reappearance in the 2018 sequel
Fallen Kingdom.
At least in the movies, heels are certainly
more sturdy than in the real world!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
heels are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.